one of these women i was talking to this
week who who we know somewhat um not
very well
um came to me and said i've been meaning
to ask you guys and she just happened to
reach me and not not you you as
biologists
what like what do you think of the
vaccine like is it
i'm hearing from anti-vaxxers i'm
hearing from people
who are who are saying they won't take
it under any circumstances
is it dangerous would you be worried
about a vaccine that was pushed through
so fast
and you know we have not talked about
this actually um
what i said to her was uh i'd far prefer
to take a vaccine
that had gone through all of the most
rigorous testing
there is no time for that i do not think
that the way in which that this vaccine
is
has the possibility of being less
effective than it should
is likely to send it into the territory
of being dangerous
i i think it is likely to be less
efficacious
than it is supposed to be rather than
more dangerous than a more reliably
tested vaccine
what do you think about that well hey
this is a perfect segue into exactly
what we were going to
be talking about um i would say one
thing i know for sure
is that we're damn well not going to be
allowed to talk about it the way we need
to talk about it in order to do this
properly we're going to be expected to
belittle the public and tell them a
fairy story about safety
in which their concerns are the result
of
wild-eyed fevered dreams yadda yadda
and the adults have tested this thing
and if we say it's safe it's safe and
all of this is complete nonsense
now the vaccine will have gone through
testing hey i don't trust the testing
right i don't trust the testing because
i've seen what happens with drug safety
testing and
when somebody in this case me tries to
raise the alarm
about a glaring flaw in that system
the bell doesn't ring so what don't i
know about vaccine testing
who knows right i would also say that
there is a second
layer of informal testing that we know
didn't happen here which is if a vaccine
emerges
and it is given to people then time
passes and it is
not a good way of figuring out whether
something has happened but over time a
pattern
will emerge that something about the
vaccine we didn't know
has occurred people who've had it are
showing this symptom something like that
in this case there just simply hasn't
been enough time there hasn't been time
for the longitudinal studies longitude
referring exactly to time in this case
that we would normally
uh assume was necessary right and
um what's more in this case uh
and i wasn't prepared to talk about this
but um
my understanding is that this vaccine as
a is of a very
interesting and i think highly unusual
type which i don't actually know
anything about it
well this is the pfizer vaccine we're
talking about yeah what i heard
was an in a high quality conversation
sophisticated people who wouldn't be
uh jawing off about this without uh
having done some work but
what i understood is that it is an mrna
vaccine
all right which i believe means the m
stands for messenger
right that doesn't give a lot of context
but well a particular type of rna
you've got dna which is made into a
template which is rna which is a close
relative of dna
that mrna is then sent to a basically a
molecular machine called a ribosome
which turns it into protein which is the
active form
right and so a this is interesting
because
the thing that the coronavirus does is
basically hijack the cell
above the genome it doesn't integrate
into the genome this is a mistake i made
on one of our first live streams and
people correct it was a retrovirus
yeah um that's the mistake you're
talking that was the mistake i
made but it turns out that this
coronaviruses are interesting in the
sense that they
uh travel above the level of the genome
they never interact with it they hijack
the ribosomes and send the messages with
the
epigenomic right well yes um
so in any case a vaccine that does the
same trick
um seems like it might actually
be quite safe on the other hand what we
don't know
about the situation might be larger than
normal because this isn't a variation on
a common theme as i understand it
so um you know no one does i mean i
guess
the danger potentially is what other
mrna does it go after
um well there's all of the upstream
danger in other words
um you can trigger the immune system
to do things at the level of antigen you
can trigger the immune system
to to be forewarned about particles that
actually are hostile before it ever sees
them
right that would be a typical way so
like a typical mechanism for
a vaccine right you would take either
broken up pieces of dead virus
or live virus that isn't pathogenic and
you would put it in the system
the system would then do what it does
normally which is recognize that there's
something
unfamiliar here it must be an enemy and
it would learn to go after it
and then at the point that the real
pathogen shows up the system is already
primed
so that's typical this is a very
different mechanism and so
um very you know uh but i had to i
haven't heard
all i've heard about the mechanism is
it's somehow engaging the mrna not what
it's doing
no no it is mrna if the vaccine
is mrna if i understand this correctly
and boy are we going to get some
corrections if i don't
yeah um that it is mrna and then what
like what what
well so the ribosomes transcribe mrna
when they run into it because
they're primed you know that's their
purpose and the stuff comes out of the
nucleus so this mrna
is going to uh come into the system
trigger ribosomes and they are going to
produce
proteins which do what um well
that's a good question do they so that's
that's the part that i don't get i don't
get
how plugging new mrna into your system
that then gets ribosomes to print new
protein deals with the coronavirus well
this protein has to have some particular
effect on the coronavirus over here so
we just
that's great that's the black box that's
there i have a connection
we should dig this up to the extent that
it is possible to do it but you know it
could be
that it is producing components of
antibodies
so antibodies for example are proteins
that have
sticky basically sticky pads on them and
those sticky pads
land on antigens that
they match and they can do all kinds of
things including gum up pathogens so
those pathogens can't access the surface
of cells and things
so rna could be causing the ribosomes to
produce proteins that are antibodies as
opposed to a more common mechanism of
vaccine which is
give give the body a little bit of
antigen itself the actual virus either
dead
or alive little pieces such that the
body is prompted to create those
antibodies well but that was going to be
my other
guess was that maybe it's producing
antigens that are
resident on viral particles and thereby
cause basically the vaccine in some
sense is being produced inside the cells
um you know so if if a ribosome produces
an antigen found on a coronavirus and
the immune system
then sees it and recognizes it as
foreign because
it's not in the library itself then that
could prime the system so anyway
definitely we should dig to the extent
that it is possible i had no idea
i had heard nothing except pfizer's got
this vaccine that
they're hoping to get rich on all right
so now well so
i will say um that when this when this
acquaintance of ours asked me
i prefaced my um you know
investigating in terms of a manipulation
of biologists but not knowledgeable with
regard to
these particulars answered to her with
we will have our family vaccinated if i
unless there is something that i do not
understand
yet about um there being an increased
risk of
danger from this sort of vaccine then a
vaccine that might not be very effective
is
is one that we should be taking well uh
i fall out quite differently here and
the problem is
to have the adult conversation is
potentially to trigger
a failure in the game theory realm that
people rightly fear
but the problem is the difference
between individual decisions from public
health right
so here's the thing we're not allowed to
say
my god wouldn't it be terrible if this
was true that the sweet spot
is for everybody else to take the
vaccine and you not therefore you don't
get the risk of the vaccine which has to
be
rated as substantial just based on the
unknowns based on the fact that there
will be no one on earth who has
had the vaccine a year ago and so we
don't know what it does a year out
right so if everybody took the vaccine
and you didn't you get the benefit of
their immunity
but nowhere close to everybody's gonna
take it right so then the game theory i
mean effectively this
because you know this this is one of the
things
that um trump really failed at
so badly early in the coronavirus
pandemic which was
polarizing it polarizing the response to
it as opposed to saying
here's what we're going to do and you
know maybe we'll have to do something
else at some other point right
but turning us into star bellied
snitches and sneetches without with
regard to masks and now vaccines
um has made it such that
it's not possible to assume that you
would be the only person in your
community who wasn't vaccinated
right so there's no way right but
uh so there's a game look the problem is
that the game
theory is relatively straightforward
right the more people who are vaccinated
the less
um you're being vaccinated actually
matters to your own
immunity assuming that the thing works
right the thing works the more people
who are vaccinated the less
you need to be vaccinated in order not
to get it because other people around
you will not have the pathogen in an
active form
if they've been vaccinated as people
register that
and they decide to play the game and
avoid the vaccine
then the number of people who've been
vaccinated goes down the risk of getting
the disease goes up and so you get into
this very ugly equilibrium
right which is what the anti-vex um
catastrophe shall we call it is about is
there is
a fear about vaccines
and people who are sophisticated about
understanding
the nature of the the game
recognize that those who opt out are in
effect
um exposing everybody else to greater
danger and
saving themselves on the risk of course
it's also true though that just as
early on the mass discussion was insane
right yes masks provide no safety
whatsoever
this turns out to have been a political
decision right and then
masks are about you protecting other
people right
what then why no yes that is also
true but of course the masks are going
to protect you as well so i see a
similar sort of
analysis possible here with regard to
vaccines the anti-vaxxers can be like
nope too dangerous i'm and if if they're
sort of savvy anti-vaxxers are going to
argue well i'm going to get my benefit
from everyone else being vaccinated
well but there are two there are two
ways
of course that you can be safe
from the disease at least two one is not
be exposed
and you don't be exposed by being safe
and so and physical distancing
and wearing a mask when you're in the
presence of others inside and all of
this
and a vaccine is a second way that you
can be protected
that also comes with risks that we
cannot fully know
but that you cannot get any other way
right
so what i would say is in the case of
the masks the
the game is exactly the same but for one
thing
which is that the cost of the masks is
very
very low for most people and you and i
disagree on this
well so no it's very very low at the
level of let's say
safety now there are people for whom it
carries a safety
risk and there are you know i mean look
you're reducing
the effectiveness of a system that is
built to exhale into the world directly
you are reducing the effectiveness you
are causing
co2 at the very least to build up at a
higher rate so there it's not like there
is going to be zero effect but you're
talking entirely about an anatomical
and physiological risk you're talking
and so over in vaccine space that is
where the risk is right entirely it's
entirely about
in and of the body yeah and the risk
from masks for people who are otherwise
healthy
for mask wearing is v is very low
exactly what you just said
yeah um but there but we are as you know
this and this is our
our drum beat right that humans like a
few other species on the planet are so
much more than just our bodies and it is
all evolutionary
and the fact of walking around not being
able to actually
exchange meaning by looking at other
people's faces
and uh and you know and
having initial interactions immediately
made
painful and suspect because you're
walking on a trail in a park
and people leap out of the way because
they see you're not masked from 12 feet
away even though you're outside in
nature
there there is simply not enough nuance
uh around the discussion and you know
it's i think it's very similar right and
um in both cases you know pro mask
pro vaccine but those aren't sufficient
categories right right pro mask
when it is under those conditions where
it is appropriate and most people don't
understand what those conditions are
and outside i know i am i am perfectly
comfortable but i don't like the looks
that i get once i'm outside of the range
of the hvac at the supermarket
immediately taking my mask off
and having as i walk through the parking
lot with my groceries
in the cart having occasionally people
glare at me no
sorry i'm outside and i'm going to
breathe the air
okay so this is in some sense a perfect
prototype that you and i did not
settle on in advance but this is exactly
the conversation both sides are stupid
here
okay to the extent that we have a
dangerous virus
that we have misunderstood the hazard of
it as hazard of death which is lower
than we thought but that there is a much
greater hazard of
brain damage uh heart damage etc
right that um there is
reason to use a mask where a mask is
effective and there is reason to
minimize mask use
right not to signal with it when we're
for example outdoors where things are
quite safe still and
again that could change but it hasn't
yet as far as we know yep
um so in any case the problem is there
is nowhere for most people to stand
because the reasonable position is not
allowed right and
um sorry asterisk from way back
governor brown's order that's about to
send us oregon into two weeks of
whatever she's calling it it's not the
full shutdown that we had in march april
because
a lot of the retail businesses are still
allowed to be open just a limited
capacity
um but among other things that are
closed is gardens
why the hell are they closing gardens
yeah unless unless they can make an
argument for it's the workers
except excuse me um you know someone
behind plexiglas taking tickets
is you know the only the only person who
needs to be there at the time
why are they closing gardens right
especially at a moment when we've got
the
you know where the windshield of the
continent and the firehose of the
pacific is on
us and if you could manage to get
outside and enjoy something you should
absolutely do it
yeah for reasons of mental health if
nothing else yes so
and so this this is my point about
actually
the you know the mask the mask analysis
is unnuanced
and the idea that well there's you know
what is it gonna hurt you
no let's take a more expansive view of
of of harm actually let's move it beyond
the physical
and the physical health and into mental
health and social health
and i mean i think it was nicholas
christakis early in this who said
maybe it wasn't him he he certainly
started to say it but
you know no we shouldn't be social
distancing we should be physical
distancing
and it's really hard to do the one
without the other
um but it's even harder when you can't
see people's faces
right so the problem is we could
outline we could sketch the
uh there's got to be a better word than
smart but the smart position in which
you pay as little cost as you have to
for masks but you get the benefit right
you want the sweet spot of how much mask
wearing to do and where is it
and how can you minimize your wearing of
masks and still get
98 of the value of them right
we can do that but the problem is the
game
theory causes a
social enforcement of a lie about
the utility and the same thing happens
in vaccine space so there are people who
will hear the discussion that we just
had
as somehow uh heresy because
it acknowledges the hazard of vaccines
and acknowledges that in this case
there's a special hazard that just comes
from the fact that it hasn't been out
very long
right and so um there has to be a way
for us to have a proper conversation and
one thing i would say is
again in the vaccine case both sides are
stupid
right we have a safety system that can't
possibly work
because of the perverse incentives
surrounding the economics of vaccine
production
right they're more dangerous than they
need to be because there's a perverse
incentive
surrounding the hazard right
that means that we are in a v we're in a
thoroughly compromised position
when it comes to the game theory and
saying to people you know what
they're not totally safe right we've
made them as safe as they can be
right we here's here's how you know that
they're as safe as they can be without
being perfectly safe and you need to
take your share of the risk along with
the rest of us
so that we can get the collective
benefit of us being immune and
frankly driving pathogens out of
existence or to very low levels
that comes from wide compliance with
these things but unfortunately
those of us who you know i think
vaccines are one of the
most powerful inventions humanity has
ever come up with but i cannot just be
a uh a booster for vec that's a terrible
term
vaccine booster i cannot be
a cheerleader for vaccines given the
economic model and the way it
compromises
safety i have to be in this camp where
you know
i'm constantly getting beaten up because
people want me to tell the public
these things are safe and you're you
know you're a conspiracy theorist for
believing they might not be
well you and i agree about um some of
the
basically the top uh
developmental discoveries of western
medicine
being vaccines antibiotics and then also
several surgical techniques
and then a whole lot of the rest of what
is going on
has has been done better in a lot of
cases by other
other traditions actually um but in part
by interfering less with physiology that
we don't understand exactly or by on by
coming on it just from a different
perspective and therefore being able to
see like with anamorphic art
something that you could not see from
the uh cut it or pellet
attitude which is increasingly what the
western medicine approach
is but you know to say that antibiotics
are one of the great
great discoveries creations of humankind
does not suggest that they haven't been
wildly overprescribed
aren't making us all sick aren't making
our cattle sick and therefore the people
that eat those cattle sick
and the people who drink the milk and
like all of these things
are also true so it does to say that
it's one of the great inventions of
humankind
does not mean that you think it's all
good all the time
so i will also say that um i think
you've
you've waited into this a little bit
more than i have so you've gotten more
pushback than i have
um but you know the idea that you are
some sort of a
vaccine denier or an anti-vaccine our
family is probably far more vaccinated
than just about anyone watching because
of where we've traveled
right and um when our kids were very
young i started pushing for us to
take them places and you i think
correctly said nope not yet
um because it because
the drugs that we need to give them to
keep them safe to travel in some of
these places are not safe for them when
they're that young
yeah the longer you wait through
development the less
harm given an amount of harm done by a
drug or a vaccine the later it comes in
development the less damaging it is
exactly and so at the point that we did
start traveling to really far-flung
places like like the amazon with them
which would have been when they were
what like 11 and 9 maybe
something like that we were able to give
them
not with perfect safety but things like
the yellow fever vaccine which is
actually
like required by law but also we would
have done had had we gone there because
it has been around for a long time
yellow fever is one of these mosquito
vector diseases that is
deadly that has wiped out whole
populations
and furthermore in that case i also feel
it is our responsibility not just to
keep us safe but to go into a place
where you are traveling into a place
where other people don't travel between
if there's any chance that you could
bring a disease in that is that's not an
acceptable risk to to bring to the
people who already live there
however we neither of us have ever
gotten the cholera vaccine
because the cholera vaccine while it's
also been around for a while is
understood not to have it's
i don't remember the numbers um
something like 30 to 40 percent efficacy
and it's not particularly dangerous but
all vaccines bring with them some risk
and the fact is that the cure for
cholera largely especially for
um you know comparatively wealthy people
north americanos
is to have access to clean water which
um we would always be able to have
access to and so we make these decisions
one by one
right uh and you know i have been
wanting a malaria vaccine since we began
traveling
uh to latin america decades ago at this
point
but that doesn't mean that as soon as
one shows up it's right away the moment
to
to take it because i've also gone
through what four different kinds of
malaria prophylaxis one of which
is completely horrifying and i hope
never to be on something like that again
so
you know you you have to be able to look
at the options before you and say
who who do i trust who knows more about
this than i do and what are they saying
and also how is it that i can rely on my
own
knowledge and make decisions for myself
that said public health is a different
kind of analysis which is where you
started here
right and so i think the the bottom line
well they're two bottom lines
one when it comes to things like
medicine
uh there's a a an analog to the
principle
that the government that governs best
governs least which does not mean
actually at least it means least
necessary to do the job
that the medicine that functions best
functions least that our tendency to
want to interfere in a system
always comes with side effects and to
the extent that there are interventions
that reduce
the intensity of the intervention they
tend to be
far better sure but once if you're
looking for a vaccine you're already in
arms race
right so a vaccine is inherently sort of
a combative property
that is going to do some some some war
somewhere on some part of hopefully most
of the pathogen you're trying to combat
but also presumably your body
right and you know what is the effect of
you know if one vaccine is great
is there or do we really imagine there's
no cost
to just vaccinating you to everything
that we can
possibly create a vaccine for or is
there some cumulative cost
i don't think we know the answer to
these questions um
so anyway one of the one of the lessons
here is about
medicine and uh a non-interventionist
bent
just as you want a light hand in
government a light hand in medicine
saves you from all of the things you
didn't know about the system you were
interfering with
um the other one has to do with the game
theory and frankly my
i'm sick and tired of being shouted at
by people
who don't want me to say the truth
because they're afraid it will cause
people to tune into the game theory and
not participate in something like
vaccines
my point is now there's actually no way
around
the adult discussion here which involves
owning up to the fact that the system
isn't nearly as safe as it might be
and that basically there are two sides
to this contract
if we're going to get if we're going to
be little people and maybe require them
to take vaccines
we have an absolute obligation to make
these things as safe as possible first
right there's no two ways about that and
so and to speak
with some nuance and to allow people the
possibility
of actually understanding what is going
on because when you make broadcast
claims like
masks do not help or vaccines are a
hundred percent
safe you of course increase the distress
that people have and increase
the non-compliance that people have with
with these rules because some of them
are clearly political and lies
and um you know we really really hope
uh that you know this or many multiple
vaccines that get produced
are not are not built on lives but
on what basis are we supposed to trust a
political pronouncement
about this at this point right the whole
landscape of discussion
discussion that masquerades as
analytical has been politicized to the
point that we are now
unable to talk about even the basics of
how we are to interact with each other
or how we are to protect ourselves from
threats that we all face
yeah and you know um whatever process it
is that allowed that to happen
has put us in very serious jeopardy and
we have to counteract it
you